they're germany's most famous jazz
musicians yo Keem kun on the piano and
his brother horf on clarinet are
definitely the meaning of life is to
play the best music you can until the
end of your life the best that you can
get out of yourself to do that you have
to practice practice practice and play
play play every day the job is
twenty-four seven but I love it every
day there's something new I love it
sleeve is if I agree that's how I feel
about it to the [ __ ] brothers belonged
to a highly select group of jazz
musicians from Germany who gained
international renown urk ms70 his older
brother hoof is 84 got shown us baby he
got it from the time he was in his baby
stroller cookie dough back then I prank
just a little more than I do now
sometimes five or six hours a day oh man
I did it next to his stroller almost
instinctively fussing thief he never
cried or screamed he listened to your
fleet and sometimes he'd go to sleep
this look look look and I thought that
was a pretty good critique the fundies
aku the hotel back in the 1960s when he
was in his early 20s raheem [ __ ] was on
his way to becoming one of Germany's
best improvisational jazz pianists
brother Ralph 15 years older had already
made it to the very top earning
worldwide recognition for two years he
played clarinet together with jazz
legend Benny Goodman and the brothers
also played together on a regular basis
they've produced a number of albums
since their first in 1967 the latest is
from 2012 improvisation is a key factor
well as my sometimes we start out of
nowhere and approach a composition that
way we can all find a compass is doing
all that happens sometimes
the Jazz Fest in bond is still a very
young festival but it's very successful
the concerts are sold out you have it's
fine while our program focuses on German
musicians we watch the European scene
very closely and try to keep up with the
times and invite exciting up-and-coming
European musicians hope Asia in Toronto
musica aight salade pianist michelle
voni is one of the new leading lights of
german jazz in bond the 36 year old is
playing together with israeli
harpsichordist tamar halperin
volney considers you a cheme [ __ ] a
major role model yo I'm if you up him is
my hero there for me he's one of the
greatest pianists in the world today if
not the greatest read by decide if I the
cameras on you are him Queen I've always
had a UI and croon syndrome when I hear
him play somewhere I'm immediately on
fire something happens to me and I'm
electrified perhaps it's the timing
maybe it's the harmonic language his
sound on the instrument he's just an
incredible pianist I'll be honest
Golf lives in Berlin drokking on Ibiza
in June the brothers will be getting
together to play at walking's place on
the Spanish island perhaps for a new
album
you